اهلا بكم
تمرد عسكري فاشل هدد بالوصول الى موسكو ثم
تذلل متراجعا لكنه شكل صفعه لهيبه بوتين
وزعزعه ثقه بهيكل نظامه تمرد قائد فاجنر
اظهر نقاط الضعف في النظام السياسي الروسي
ووضع دائره بوتين المقربه تحت المجهر
فالتمردات تؤشر اما الى عدم الرضا اي
انقلابات اخرى محتمله مصبغه مقبلا او تشكل
فرصه لتطهير المشتبه بعدم ولائهم وبالتالي
تعزيز قبضه السلطه هيكليه نظام المحيط
بالرئيس الروسي تنقسم الى قسمين المجموعه
الاولى هم التكنوقراط الذين يهيمنون على
الحكومه لكن دون سلطه التدخل في الشؤون
الامنيه اما بالنسبه للمجموعه الثانيه فهي
نخبه الكريم او دائره بوتين المقربه
نواتها ما تعرف في مجموعه سلوفيكي وهؤلاء
هم اصدقاء بوتين منذ عقود ومؤثرون بتغذيه
قراراتها السياسيه والامنيه
عددهم العشره اشخاص معظم اهم الرؤساء
الوكالات العسكريه الامنيه والمخابرات لكن
اكثرهم تاثيرا نيكولاي باتروشيف وهو
سكرتير مجلس الامن الروسي ويلقب بالصقر
وهو ثاني اقوى رجل في روسيا اما
فهو رئيس جهاز المخابرات الخارجيه الروسيه
الحالي ورئيس السابق لمجلس الدوما معرفته
ببوتين تتجاوز 30 عاما فيما يلعب
وهو رئيس جهاز الامن الاتحادي الروسي يلعب
دورا رئيسيا بالحفاظ على سيطر بوتين لكنه
اقل تاثيرا على الرئيس من باتروشيب او
ناري شكيب اما اذا ذهبنا الى وزير دفاعه
هو لم يختم في الكي جي بي او الجيش لكنه
يقضي بانتظام اجازات قصيره للصيد مع بوتين
ما يتيح له الوصول المباشر للرئيس دون
عوائق رغم انها قبضه بوتين على الائت لاف
الذي يبقيه في السلطه اضعف من اي وقت مضى
لكن ذلك لا يعني ان ايامه باتت معدوده
بالسلطه بل يرجح امكانيه تحديه هو وجود
منافسين اخرين لبوتين
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات